[Music]
good morning Millennials oh very low you
brought that in like Anna base morning
my god oh wait your voice sounds all
better by the way thank you I'm trying
did you do anything no I'm trying to get
better but I haven't taken anything or
really cared for myself I had a tea by
the end of the night and I've been going
to sleep so late which by the end of the
night now like I'm all talked out for
the day and I haven't no voice and then
I sleep and I worry that I won't be able
to do my job no when it's like the only
thing you can really do to help that is
like to stop talking but that's [ __ ]
impossible no but for me like I welcome
the chance I mean I was alone all day
yesterday and I was talking the whole
time how like I'm on the phone I'm on
FaceTime I took myself I talked to Theo
like cuz you can't actually like be
alone in silence no never
for me it is a dream to be alone there
are some days I don't know what day
specifically when I used to work in a
corporate office and before I was
seating Zack and I like hated my life
and those words up to there were days
where like I would like see how long it
took before I said something like it
maybe before I think I'd like so like
maybe lunchtime when I like has asked
tuna right the chicken rahzel-chan yeah
so like but until then I might not talk
to anyone that's so great briefly Jackie
and hey is this for Jackie or like now
it's like by the time it's noon you're
talking oh my god I'm all talked out I
wish there was an app like how there is
the health app for taking steps an app
for like how much you spoke words yeah
words spoken per minute yeah like throat
app totally I don't know how to measure
that we have so many projects that we
like need to develop before we couldn't
get to this one what's the what's our
name for this app Oh word count yeah
yeah words with friends I think that
one's available yeah do too so yeah
before that we have tienen right we've
so many things we have so many things
we've shark tank well good morning
happy Friday everyone welcome back to
the morning toast I'm feeling
reinvigorated of my love for the toast
it's just it's good to be back it's good
to be back yesterday was so fun yes it
was the longest day ever like
yesterday's episode feels like forever
ago yeah my outfit like really didn't
seit on camera so today I just gave up
completely but have some very active day
so I really needed to be in like no
you're wearing joggers right and I also
like have a fanny pack with me be
September joggers Paul Paul
joggers got it you know but she finally
made joggers we were offline when the
announcement was but she by Sheree did
come out with joggers to middle to and
now everyone is following in her
footsteps easy is really seeing joggers
and I heard they're inspired by Sheree
easy and bendy joggers that's the whole
thing because obviously what she said
like wasn't so crazy if you know please
you know if you've ever seen the Kanye
interview where like years ago where he
said like joggers are the future it was
the weirdest thing but it was but he was
right because like look it I wouldn't be
wearing this right if he hadn't said the
dog so when she said that joggers has an
answer it was an ode to joy' intuitive
she was an it was an ode to the entry
yay - yay well what else do I even need
to recap before we dive right in
I mean I don't know we could always
think of something House CEO just so
busy you know being a precious gem of a
man who fled his country and sought
refuge in America with nothing to his
name with the bustling medical practice
right it's just like he's really truly
an inspiration if you think about it
like he's the American Dream the
American dream just a thought just some
Friday inspiration should we do to your
toasters today it's been seven years
sure all right let me go pull I don't
know where to be me neither okay hang on
I'd say I do snitch and I are on a
mission oh my god I'm having so many
from problems I've reached maximum
storage with my phone which I don't
think there's anything worse it takes
over your whole life oh you just have to
get a new phone right and it's like this
is a new phone this is an iPhone Ted
have you reached maximum storage I don't
know maybe it's because I have over
20,000 photos that could be it maybe
it's all the facetiming know it's of the
20,000 photos being stored Jackie of the
20,000 photos I would say more than half
are screenshots of like memes like I
need to start to Liddy my likes that
takes up no space yeah actually you know
what takes up the most
it's my text yeah you need to delete
your text but how here like with my hand
no you can edit click click click so I
click Add amass delete but that's like I
love my texts I've such precious
memories with my texts yeah it's like
you like your photos but
you love my text messages I just also
hate like I never save anyone's phone
number so when they text me and I don't
have the number I read our old message
and I infer I'm like you know Nancy Drew
like that but if I don't have any recent
text messages I'm never gonna know who's
texting me maybe that's a blessing
though you're not gonna know anyway
because oh my god you and inferring
Jaggi I have to tell you the most
terrible thing that happened to me I
think I know what that Harry Styles know
the Megan McCain of it all
oh the two things happened then I don't
well first of all Megan McCain was in
Vegas when I was in Vegas because she
was also seeing gaga so crazy that Megan
King goes to Vegas I know and she like
had the best time and I was text she was
in gaga yeah but I'm different Knight
than me but we were just DMing I'm like
oh my god I'm in Vegas when she just
landed I'm you're like making plans and
she was like by the way like my husband
really wants to meet you because he
heard that you called him hot on the
toast and I'm like how did the chest get
into Megan McCain's house you know and
it was through her in-laws apparently
her sister-in-laws a toaster so thanks
whoever that girl is like for hooking it
up so I was like dying of shame already
you know and then this is so terrible
Jackie like I am an embarrassment so she
was like let's get together okay tindy
she was like let's get together you have
my number right and she said her number
and I do have her number and I have
texted her like two or three times over
the course of a year just like random
things happy birthday
you look great on watch up inside look
random things just like you know to
prolong the friendship she has never
answered and they all went through his
blue iMessage so I was like okay so she
sent me her phone number she's like you
have it right and the last digit was
wrong so I was like oh I so I sent her a
screenshot I'm like I've been texting
you for like a year I guess I had the
wrong number and she goes oh wait no
sorry I typed it wrong and that she
retouch it and I had the right number
the whole time and like she just wasn't
answering me she was like oh my god so
many people text me like all the time
with that I never know who they are I'm
like I'm sure but like and I wasn't ever
upset that she didn't answer like now
I'm embarrassed right sure she's telling
the same story and she's embarrassed
like that she was called out that she
didn't respond and and she does like you
so like if you're not like she's trying
to ignore you it was one of the most
shameful I think we've we have a
situation where we have to embarrass ATO
women even neither is pregnant right
exactly and
the bed in Vegas with Martin be
adjustable crop and I like screamed at
the top of my lungs I was like it was so
terrible and actually did you know that
on Bravo like last week they replayed
their their New Year's Eve special more
they did that special where he made out
with aunt with Tamra at New Year's they
did a live yeah your show there were so
many Bravo liberties Meghan McCain was
on that interesting I know I thought it
was so funny like she really has deep
roots in Bravo no she does and she's
really doing it Oh doing it right yeah
you know totally she gets like the
seriousness and the respect of ABC and
the view but she gets to have a good
time every now and then and go on
watched up and diving like drink
margarita and she could like I feel like
if she ever once a good time once a
totally Gaga like there she is yeah
because she's like young and cool but
respected I'm just young and cool I get
no respect no no no what would you even
do without their respective away I don't
want to be respected for like at least
five years okay that's fair you'll be 30
oh my god that's so old it's so crazy
I feel like 30s actually like everyone's
like your twenties are the best time
you're right but like I feel like I'm
really looking forward to like the more
relaxing 30s where like there's less
pressure like the country-club 30s right
oh my god she had a dream we got into
the Country Club and I was like kind of
paid about him I go now we have to go to
the country club but we haven't gotten
in yet I should send a follow-up yeah I
don't I just think it's not like a
member adding season like there are
seasons for adding members Yeah right
before summer I feel like this is
actually member adding season I don't
know we'll see I don't know I'm just
like I'm waiting for my follow up from
from the country club like an interview
something I would love an interview me
too I would kill it I would wear a
collared shirt with a pleated skirt and
you burn CEO mmm you would win them over
and over country club lost what they
don't like Phil you know cup some of his
world famous borscht
maybe maybe then Dave would respect me
okay let me pull up some dear toasters
if you guys don't if folks some new
toasters dear toasters is our advice
segment you can send anonymous advice to
your toasters at gmail.com
we will never reveal your identity
unless you want us to and we're breaking
down given advice not very good advice
for anything from you know bridal drama
family drama DNA drama but we've had
some sperm bank drama the more
interesting and weird the better but
feel free to send it along too dear to
us or such email com I'm gonna pull some
up because we have so many that we have
in my DNA drama oh my
you're doing that I just want to address
what happened in the comments yesterday
okay but really quickly because everyone
is popping off and Wilding out and just
when I know it's all it's handled in the
words of Olivia Pope okay there were
trolls yesterday in imposter ring some
of our biggest interest Roasters and I
have to be honest I gave your toaster
you got him pastored like that can only
be a cop it's an honor it's an honor and
if you didn't get imposter I should I
would really hate I would just work a
little harder than ya hard just takes a
little hard work okay I got the tier
toasters ups okay do that later are you
ready for the first story which is like
the only story of the day everyone's
talking about Kevin Hart sat down with
Ellen what's so crazy is that everyone's
talking about it and it hasn't even
aired yet only a seven-minute clip was
played on The Today Show right well so
but the rollout has been has been good
yes because yesterday she announced that
she didn't interview with Kevin Hart she
was gonna release it next week but she's
actually racing it tomorrow which is
today then this morning seven minutes
came out and the interview is airing on
her show this afternoon
yes okay so we'll get the large portion
of her later but I have to imagine this
was the meat the meat of it um
so it opens ellen is sharing her you
know one-on-one conversations with the
academy i wonder like when you say the
academy right who who are you talking
and she just makes it seem like she just
picked it up and died like 9-1-1 like
it's a place everyone can call yeah but
she has them on speed dial i just gave
him a ring right and it's like the
academy this the academy not be like you
have to only be talking to like one
person right is it like the president
who knows well she made it seem like
they still really want him to host they
haven't found anyone yet because i think
they're still hoping that he will do it
and after watching this interview i'm
fairly certain he is going to do it so
we're just gonna give you the highlights
as told to you by People magazine it's
the first time Kevin Hart has given an
interview about the topic since he
announced he was stepping down from his
role as Oscars host on December 6th a
mere two days after being given the job
during those days previous homophobic
comments Hartmut had made re-emerged
online leading the Academy of Motion
Picture of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences science pleased to ask so true
she asked to ask the actor for an
apology they please Isaac Newton is
right rolling right because apples but
as
told the generous heart had already
apologized for his words quote it was an
attack he told Alan this wasn't an
accident
this wasn't a coincidence it wasn't a
coincidence that the day after I
received the job that tweets just
somehow manifested from 2008 I don't
know who follows me or who doesn't but
I'm on social media every single day I
have over 40,000 tweets to go through
40,000 tweets to get back to 2008 that's
an attack that's animilitia s-- attack
on my character quote quote that's an
attack to end me that's not an attack to
you and the Oscars that's an attack to
end me he continued this was to destroy
me this was to end all partnerships all
brand relationships all investment
opportunities studio relationships my
production company and the people work
underneath me this was to damage the
lives that had been invested in me it's
bigger than just the Oscars it's about
the individuals who are out there now
that are finding success in damage
they're finding success in damaging your
quote celebrity so I don't necessarily
agree with everything he said but he
does make a really interesting point in
like every time it's like someone gets
cancelled and there's like tweets like
the people who find it are acting like
they're doing this world justice like we
figured it out like she worships Satan
in her closet when she goes home like
they act like they're doing the world a
favor when it let's call a spade a spade
like you're being you're you're looking
to destroy or like remove an opportunity
from someone and like that's fine just
own it like but they do it under the
mask of like I'm doing this for the
greater good like if we didn't know this
like we would die you know right it's
like forty thousand tweets and three are
offensive that's all he stands for right
not the forty thousand other things that
he said over ten years now I'm just so
confused by this and I was reading I'm
firmly in the middle on this issue
because given my particular life
experience but I mean I'm really reading
both sides because I'm trying to see
like what I understand and I was just
seeing a lot of tweets from the gay
community this morning just like really
not happy with Ellen and when I think
about it I'm like Ellen really defines
to kind of like labels or identities one
is like the first gay woman on
television like she came out on TV like
she is a pioneer an icon like she got a
medal from Obama like she is important
in the community but she's also a light
like I've been a comedian her whole life
and comedians are very much of the
mindset
we don't apologize like the point of our
job is to disrupt and make people feel
uncomfortable in like that's comedy and
like if you like it great if you don't
bug you and that's their stance and
they're very like staunchly unapologetic
but as like this gay icon like it's her
job to like make sure that you know gay
people are being protected and like
there's good conversations happening
so she really out of anyone like Falls
the most in the middle but she took this
like complete side of the comedian being
like [ __ ] the trolls like she didn't
really and maybe she did she will
because there's so much of the
conversation we haven't seen yet but
like she didn't even really talk about
what he said no but it seems like she's
approaching this at least from the clip
I've seen from like a post apology
standpoint which I really appreciate
because it's like how many times does
one person have to apologize if she said
come on my show and apologize he would
be like I apologize that's true
you know at certain point what's the
point of an apology if people can't
accept it and move on right like if you
keep having to say it right so true I
appreciate that work where PA
we're post apology yeah and now it's
like how do we move forward from here
and I really appreciate that she's
taking a stand against canceled culture
yeah me too because it's time it's time
but people are not happy with Ellen like
these things I was reading they were
just like I'm sure I don't remember but
yeah but they were making good points
and I was like yeah every time I read
something about this regardless of whose
side they're on I'm like yeah they're
right oh that's a good point so I can't
decide really where I'm at I am I am
appreciative that this conversation
about tweets and canceled culture is
finally happening like maybe I should
have in like a little bit earlier yeah
and my like a little salty that like
he's been given like the opportunity of
a lifetime like people are being so like
forgiving and understanding like and I
don't think he's doing enough with that
like that's annoying me and like I'm
jealous and I can only think of like if
people have been a third is
understanding about our situation like
oh my god I would have I would have been
so appreciative I mean you're a pioneer
yeah truly in the cancel culture I was
the first person ever to Kenzo know you
know and you and I won't be Gillespie
the last no I agree with you I I'm glad
this conversation is happening because
in the past it's never even been a
conversation it's just off with their
heads
right so it's both with their brands
right and like let's have a meaningful
discussion without just being like oh
you can't be in any movies and you can't
be a brand
like let's have the conversation like
let's talk about it you know why does
have to be like this absolute like peace
out and every time I look I'm sure if I
just was scrolling through the comments
right now I'm not watching like people
probably making valid points and I kept
every sign it's valid points that's the
thing and you know what cool that's the
thing the thing is every side has valid
points here as a Kevin Hart stand and
also someone who has a different take on
all of this due to personal experience I
think she's handling it quite graciously
it's so funny because he's being so
serious in this interview and like he's
just still so funny we always say like
he's the perfect example of a comedian
who's physically funny like just the way
they even if it's like ordering lunch
like that's funny
know it even if it's apologizing that's
funny like Jack Black is like that and I
do think one that he will host the
Oscars and I think that if he does it
will really say something about you know
our society moving forward and no longer
just subscribing to this yeah and it's
like we come from the internet which is
like sensitivity like central like you
have to watch your words and like
everyone is very in tune with their
feelings but now I'm coming up on one
year anniversary of the dirty jeans
store so now I'm like kind of looking at
it through a lens of like just a
comedian who wants to make people laugh
and that's why I think I like I stand so
firmly in the middle cuz with like the
the background of like being an
influence or like you're used to like
you know every word yeah internet troll
community like atmosphere but then when
you are in a comedy club and like no
one's recording like you could say
whatever you want like and now I'm like
just watching so many people stand like
I just started watching Bill burr who's
like very like barstool like don't
doesn't give a [ __ ] and it's like it's
shocking yeah so I think I did I stand
firmly in the middle just because of
that but like I said I still don't have
an opinion here and I'm not gonna say
anything that's gonna upset anyone cuz
like Kevin Hart didn't you know oh wait
he didn't come out for you right yeah
Ellen is really the only person right
she's the perfect ambassador for this on
behalf of Kevin Hart and the Academy
it's just so weird like I didn't know
they knew each other no but like
everyone knows each other and then when
she made a joke about when she was like
I'm not gonna get like what
I didn't tell you I didn't think you
know it that was so funny and that's
just that's the conversation right
that's funny that's funny and no one is
upset by that
yes Ellen's not and if Ellen's on its
head I'm not upset so anyways I
encourage everyone to watch this clip
and then I will watch larger interview
but I have to imagine this is like the
hot ya moment and just doing like a like
a PR perspective like this is a
brilliant pairing for kick Kevin yeah
cuz like it Ellen sanctions you the
world can cuz like Ellen is and just
like my personal perspective I really
hope he hopes the Oscars well so because
I wanted to watch Jackie I heard and I
only heard this in like a comment
section but people were saying that
Catherine zeta-jones and Halle Berry
were like the next about to be announced
I didn't I don't know if that's true or
not that's odd
that's odd is that otter unless odd than
Andy Samberg and Sandra way less odd I
mean Halle Berry is was like the she was
the first black woman to win Best
Actress or Best Supporting Actress she's
an icon in the Oscars world for sure and
I don't know what happens are we are we
diverting from comedy in hosting right
and then really like its tortured well
then it just like a boring show
it's a ready boring and there's nothing
more boring than like not funny people
reading jokes written for them by other
people cuz then it's just like you don't
even get the joke you're just repurpose
how I get off and then it's like even if
someone else wrote it like you have to
stand up like you have you that you own
that joke totally do you stand behind it
totally you shouldn't okay well that's
the big news of the day everyone can go
home just kidding okay next up Bethenny
Frankel's flight forced to turn around
because of her fish allergy oh my god I
was watching her live to beat this whole
thing were you yes I mean I'm not on
Twitter so I really don't know like I
guess I miss a lot of things but then I
find out from from the Joseph yeah so
yeah truly from the toes really we're
giving you the highlights
Bethenny Frankel has had another fishy
encounter this time at 35,000 feet weeks
after surviving a near-fatal allergic
reaction to fish the Real Housewives of
New York star realized that bass was
being served aboard a flight she took
Thursday quote called airline mult
ex to say I have fish allergy God way
she doesn't tween English multix means I
called the airline multiple times oh my
god yes I wasn't reading it I was just
literally Morse code I was like what
[ __ ] if she's like this yeah I was like
wink with both eyes yeah can you not
know one of them is cooler like this one
this one's like hey baby this one is
like hey baby
you know not as cool but yes I have the
ability to do both is that special yes
very much so and they say you have no
talent
now bet burger one no template she got
on in there serving bass quote they
couldn't not serve it they said then
they were turning around which I
protested because we delay people have
been asked to not serve it and pilot
made announcement to plane that was fun
hashtag Eppie life it was unclear which
airline Frankl was flying but the
reality TV star said quote they know who
they are
Franklin cited a recent story about a
Brooklyn boy who died suddenly after
surviving after suffering a possible
allergic reaction to the smell of
cooking fish quote there are seven
allergen groups and fewer are airborne
the allergy the airlines and world needs
to change
I was always self-conscious about it and
today didn't help she wrote being
trapped in the cabin with no windows
with cooking fish is a death trap she
added another tweet to clarify some
allergens are transmitted by touch and
air fish is one and is fatal she said I
never knew that that is there's so many
things that are so crazy about this that
the airplane would have rather turned
around than just not served fish right
so stupid and she did call in advance I
would love to know what airline this is
I literally on my flight home from Vegas
we were like so late cuz I need to be
the first one to board so I was like
running and I made a stop to get peanut
butter M&Ms from Hudson News cuz they're
the best snack on an airplane and
they're just my favorite and I was like
so excited and the second I get on the
plane they're like there's some what the
peanut allergy we're not serving peanuts
if you have any peanuts accented and
like I couldn't eat it wait I know
that's never happened because I was
gonna say oh that's having to be many
time can't believe this isn't a bigger
issue maybe because I don't think listen
to the announcement yet I've heard on
like a few times only for peanuts being
like we're not serving peanuts and if
you have peanuts please don't open them
interesting and I didn't know from
Bethany that there are people who can
like have allergy attacks just be son
smell or like touch that I did know but
I didn't know that
I don't know I didn't I never thought of
this as an issue and how am I mean and
she just like first of all not only can
she like afford to buy private most of
the time but like she has a platform
where she can complain about this but
like imagine how many people like to
suffer and coach no totally and that's
such a good Quinn there's no windows
it's your air but I guess being coach is
better cuz they don't serve fish because
they don't serve anything right true she
should have
so did they turn it around um what is
happening they turned it around that's
nuts
oh my god I would be so mad if I was a
passenger like who was who was diverted
just because like they wouldn't throw
the fish away that would not be a divine
version not at all not at all
that sucks really like I don't even know
I just can't believe this doesn't happen
more often well it happens pretty pretty
but like there was like these legends
like when we were younger there was like
this girl in Canada remember this story
was making out with her boyfriend and he
had a peanutbutter sandwich and she died
it was like a litterbug myth you know
like yeah who's bougie ghost story movie
stuff do you want to hear something so
crazy
that you probably know but I've never
told the toaster so my first kiss in
life was with someone who had like a
deadly human allergy and we were like
dating and I'm like the seventh grade in
the seventh grade so like where you like
someone asked about online and then you
never talked until you got home and get
on the computer you never talk until you
break up right so when we like we're
planning for our first kiss at someone's
apartment so like I couldn't eat peanuts
or peanut prep I literally couldn't eat
all day some people I was like brushed
her teeth meant like you couldn't eat
peanuts no but it wasn't just peanuts it
was like yeah whatever so I just starved
honestly that's that's what you do for
true life I think your breath is
terrible when you don't eat but of
course I think like that was before I
had a good breath I was just a kid yeah
no that is so funny no and we it's so
weird because like people are plagued by
allergies but no one in our family is
allergic to anything Ben's not allergic
to anything so it's like I'm allergic to
bee knock on wood Oh actually that's
true but I don't I know I got stung by a
bee looking insect one time and I have
to go to hospital and like blew up in
hives and it was just nasty but I don't
think it was a bee I think it was like
something that would have caused anyone
oh to go to the hospital yeah maybe just
like like so I've lived my life like
free of and I have seasonal allergies oh
that doesn't count
yeah is my life like free of this like
chip on people have like literally a
chip on their shoulders because their
allergies like really affect their lives
whereas like I just feel like I didn't
even know about this until Bethany I
think I feel like there's like two
different ways you can go about
allergies like you can tweet about it
all day long
you can be like Margot Lewin who's been
my best friend for 20 years and every
time we go to a restaurant I am reminded
that she has allergies because I had no
clue like I ordered some of salmon for
us and then it came in she was like oh
no I can't have like I can't eat salmon
oh wait yeah no clue because you're so
not annoying about it right no yeah it's
like it's life or death sometimes so
like so I understand like the annoying I
guess then there's also two types of
allergies life or death and just like
like when you used to lie and say you
were allergic to apples remember you
were like I am NOT allergic but to the
pesticides that are used to worship to
grow fruit uh-huh like if I don't
thoroughly wash an apple but we're like
cherries for example I can't eat I
really make my throat itch if I have an
apple and I don't wash it um it just
season but if I wash it thoroughly and I
get rid of the pesticides I'll be okay
right but like you that's something that
mazes like you being allergic to the
smell of fish know if that person goes
out to be dramatic no yeah it's not the
same at all but I'm also allergic to
fruit on like a an an ideological level
you know I just don't like I'm anti so
conceptually I'm against fruit my body
rejects the concept of like a healthy
sugary snack no not even healthy right
yeah it's like the good calories like
not even most fruits are just sugar
totally new stuff and it's also so crazy
that there are people who are allergic
to something their whole life and then
like something happens they get some
shot or whatever that they can start
eating like peanut butter or dairy like
one of them are I remember one of Margo
our little sisters friends there are so
many Margo's in my life these days that
I need to specify was allergic to dairy
her whole life and then she like kind of
grew out of it and like Margo was there
the first time she ever had ice cream in
her whole life like that's crazy that is
crazy
like I think like I would be devastated
if I was allergic to dairy or gluten I
think I think gluten dairy is likely
peanuts like and also if you take like a
lactate or something right you can go
around it yeah you can certainly yeah no
I think gluten that's so curiously
for me like a slice of pizza would be
worth a bellyache but a slice of pizza
is gluten and dairy damn son well Ben's
sister and she's actually really not
annoying about it either but I just
remembered she's allergic to gluten and
dairy so she literally can't
anything that's what she says getting
mm-hmm must be nice throws and cons
totally okay next story drama in today's
tax fraud scandals Bar Refaeli could
face tax fraud and perjury charges
that's what texts Fred supermodel Bar
Refaeli was notified by his Raley
authorities Thursday that she may be
charged with tax law fraud damn and
perjury for lying that she was living
with Leonardo DiCaprio in the u.s. even
though her primary residence was in Tel
Aviv according to report the city cannot
shake this act this relationship like
all she's known for really in America is
dating leo and it's like even in Israel
she's like charged with dating Leah
totally but like it's like yeah in
America she was like in Sports
Illustrated and was really like Leonardo
DiCaprio was a longtime girlfriend for a
while before he like Nina like years ago
if you go to Israel she's literally on
every billboard in the airport like
before you even leave she's ever the
jewelry Pandora Harlan Caroline and now
I'm seeing she's the owner of sunglasses
chain Carolina if you go to Israel like
every ad is like for this eyeglass cover
this eyeglass company or eighth Stern
told she's in all the pictures for the I
got some because she's the number one
model in Israel like buy along buy it
yeah
got those coming up she's gonna put my
bed of a model I bet if we went back to
Israel now Gaga though it is everywhere
probably anyways it turns out she owns a
sunglass company but she's suspected of
not declaring income received outside
Israel between 2009 and 2012 at a value
of some twenty three million shekels or
6.1 million dollars according to
Israelis I 24 News him she makes Bank
yeah from 2006 to 2007 she told tax
officials in United States that she was
a resident of Israel and told tax
officials in the gym escape the choosing
residence at the time she was eating
DiCaprio that is shady that's shady I
just feel like of all the places to be
like commit like convicted of a crime
like Israel is not a place I wanna be
commission of a crime like they take
that [ __ ] seriously and they take it
personally I'm like if you end up in
jail you're in jail with like terrorists
no and it's like things must be bad cuz
she's like up there top five israeli
ambassador is right and like she does
good work for like as being the face of
israel i'm like you know what if she's
gonna cheat on her taxes like i feel
like they would let that go right so it
must it must be really nice looking bad
and I related it so wholeheartedly cuz I
paid my taxes yesterday because I pay
quarterly just so that when a year comes
like in April I don't have to pay
big check but it's like every four
months like I died a little bit inside
like I have no money actually the checks
have been cashed yet but like when they
are I'll have no money and like you're
just gonna have to spot me okay and Ezio
is like really coming up in the medical
field so he'll spot you I haven't done
my taxes yet and I was actually just
thinking about them cuz the year is over
so like now it would be a good time to
start doing tax related preparations
yeah and also it's like it's kind of
unfair because there's no like tax
course no do you know what I mean like
you learn all this [ __ ] in school
mitochondria what is the 1099 like I
just need I need like I need there to be
some like a google for taxes what's the
difference between a 1099 and a w-9 or a
w-2 just wait I got some and then by the
way if there's a w-2 and a w-9 that
means there's aw three four five six
seven eight right like in a hell are
those no right so thankfully TurboTax
live is a new way to do your taxes it
combines tech with on-demand tax pros
who can answer your questions and offer
personalized advice
that's right wheel CPAs and EAS can help
you with your return and find all the
deductions that apply to you so you can
rest assured you're doing the taxes
right which is like I get kept up at
night that I do it wrong you know right
they're tax experts are there when you
need them so you can file with complete
peace of mind
TurboTax live with CPAs and EAS on
demand see all the details at turbo tax
calm now this is a product I can get
behind right and here we are getting
behind it exactly um I'm actually gonna
do that once I can like definitely
especially for our work like every now
and then I have a good question and I'm
like I got a call leave a message you
leave a note for the accountant like I
just want to ask like hey do I do this
or that right and these modern times
like things aren't as cut and dry as
they as they are like if you're a small
business owner or self-employed like
then it's really hard if you work for
major company they pretty much like
cover you and you just have to file your
tax returns yeah but like they give you
your tax that's easy but it's like
technical freelancers who are
self-employed first of all you get taxed
so much higher because there's a huge
self-employment tax in New York and like
what what are the rules like there needs
to just be like this like I just need
someone to be like yo send a text to
like yeah was this right you know what's
a w-2 and that's what TurboTax I've is
4tg t [ __ ] J okay speaking of
some more international news a new
survey has come out that nearly
nearly everyone loves jackieo who did
the survey Zack no Thea
a new survey has come out that nearly
everyone's obsessed with the morning
toast
a new survey has come out the nearly
half of Britain once Prince Charles to
abdicate after queen elizabeth ii what
does abdicate mean skip skip I'm June
first cadets I said so mean a new survey
shows that almost half of the British
public wants Prince Charles to abdicate
the throne following the death of queen
elizabeth ii I mean like I can't even
talk about the death of Queenie vibes no
it's gonna be such a sad day she's an
incredible Queen and really beloved by
all I don't know what the survey is on
her but I'm sure it's overwhelmingly
positive the survey conducted by BMG
research on behalf of the independent
reveals that 46% of the British public
wants Charles who's first in line for
the throne and the longest serving heir
apparent to give it up so that Prince
William can take the throne well here
for it honestly this is like a hurtful
it's basically like hey Prince Charles
we did a survey half the country doesn't
like you die okay
and you know what's so crazy I'm like
I'll never I said switch yes yes I know
you're on my last nerve
I said switch no honestly he's
definitely a case of the princess way of
course and it just will always really
like boggle my mind that Prince Charles
who is old as [ __ ] like has a mom do you
mean and a dad you love his dad yes oh
my god like oh like Jews don't live past
like 75 I can't relate to that on any
sort of level it's a Jewish thing and
it's also like a modern medicine all the
resources in the world today right and
it's I mean I'm here for the abdication
that just means we're one step closer
search like a Kate Middleton Queenie
vibes maybe like if she mysteriously
dies like I'm egged Marco you know I
feel like knighted Markel is the type of
girls who killed Kate Middleton in her
sleep so she could be the great no but
she wouldn't even be so I don't think
she has to sleep with one eye open it's
cuz then it's their kids like then Oh
Charlotte George no for Queen no for
Queen I know it doesn't work that way
like there's not always a king in Queen
right right that but that will never
make sense to me it's like it's so
simple
king and queen their kids princess
princess when they grew up King like I
will never understand why like its Queen
Elizabeth and Prince Philip but no I
will never understand how its Prince
William and Duchess Kate right like
she's a princess and so
if you marry a prince here princess I'm
Eric imagine like Rivenbark Alisa
touches to Matt yeah Duchess of Sussex
imagine rising the ranks you're marrying
a prince and you're still mad princess
I'm like when you just marry a prince
like Disney taught us your princess and
so by the way is technically the
princess
Camilla because we have to have a
princess no she's not she's a duchess
there were no princess well youyou
Jeannine right Beatrix are princesses
yes the daughters of the Queen okay
no granddaughters said the daughters of
the queen who was the daughter of the
Queen there isn't just Charles is her
kid right two more kids yes Oh Brigid no
Fergie was married to Andrew Andrew was
her son Andrew was her son she has four
kids I have two eyes them girls that
guess where who are that means kids
let's find out there's Charles Windsor
daughters there's Charles and so she's a
princess
where's who's Anne you think she would
be morphic daughter
Prince Andrew Sheila Edward Prince
Princess Anne she's alive
and she is she'll deliver yeah she looks
like she looks literally just like the
wind Wow and it's crazy that's the
Queen's daughter that's what I'm saying
it's like they call these ancient people
like are someone's kids who's still a
lot oh look at her wedding photos she's
made glam like where is the justice for
man she's a real princess right a
princess a princess
it's just so funny cause like when you
think of a princess you think of like a
teenage girl think of me as her mama
like you don't think of like a seven
year old woman being a princess like
she's a queen right but they can only be
one now so I'm sure someone will give me
a detailed explanation as to why there
as to why Prince Philip isn't the king
but I just refuse to subscribe to that
narrative in my mind like the next king
and queen are rolling in Kate and I will
give them that respect right that and if
they were to die Harry and Megan would
be king and queen like that's just a way
that I see it right no but if they were
to die George is the king and then so
could could there be a king in the Queen
eyes like siblings or they have to be
married I think back in the day there
could be but I don't know if if if if
the law allows we could if we could if
that would be palpable but if society
compel it that okay
no yeah like I'll just never
and I honestly I don't think British
people understand it either and they
don't they're not obsessed with like the
Royal like dynamics as we are like
Claudia Americans made them into
celebrities no Claudia they are so upset
are you sure yes these the royal
weddings this all this chops with the
mugs but those people who fly to the
Royal Wedding aren't from like London
you know London or like get out there
are people who fly to the Royal Wedding
and they're like no yes London people
it's just like people who live in New
York it's like too cool for school right
like you think that you like the Empire
State Building doesn't faze us right but
Great Britain you're like I'm the outer
people who like living the English
countryside they live for the elitist in
the city are like get out like they
cause traffic that's the way we feel
like when the president comes to town
first sure so London is like the New
York yeah I guess that's true okay fair
fair but everyone else they're totally
obsessed they're more obsessed than we
are for sure because I only came
obsessed because of the crown and thank
you I only became obsessed because Kate
Middleton like it was just like so
jealous of her story in high school but
according to Melanie Bromley I believe
like oh so so you're about to say
something untrue like I don't think
skipping Charles isn't even an option oh
really yes like like we all um well he
would have to abdicate okay so like yes
he could abdicate but that would have to
be his choice but based on like 46% of
public opinion like he's not abdicating
like he would have to not want to be a
royal but based on all of his like life
he is he's been through treachery like
he he wants it yeah it's like all of
that just to pass it up right hell no
like he went to that boys school his
wife Diana like he went through so much
treachery because he was born being a
royal and there's one upside of being a
royal being royal you think he would
pass that up right and when I once
explored this Avenue because I was like
oh my god we're skipping we're skipping
Charles it's possible that William and
Kate wouldn't even want that because the
longer they're not king and queen or
king and Duchess right the more normal
semblance of a life that they have then
they have to like then it snowed they
take it now like their royal like for 70
years and that's not fun
no I agree I don't think you should
abdicate and then he children and then
George is first in line and so just like
Elizabeth and Charles look like brother
and sister not son and daughter no I
know
I mean son and mom look here's a picture
of them Brady look like husband a wife
do you fill up she's still mad cute and
she's such a great Queen mm-hmm like
she's just she brings all the Queenie
vibes right
and like I'm sorry but Charles is not
king material no he doesn't give me that
kind of King buy but like maybe it's
something you grow into you're not just
like given he's grown totally grown as
hell he's grown I have he's older than
most people will have the vision to live
of living - how old is he
I'm looking um 70 all right it's not
that old but like it's old its oh yeah I
guess living to seventies I know but
maybe something about being British
because honestly I just found this out
Trump is 70 that's like so old for a
president but it's like he looks like he
has 30 years on Prince Charles like
they're the same age I went to high
school together
that's crazy right when I then I turn by
70 I was like what that it's so old like
we're present cuz when you're president
you have to be at least 35 so I guess
they're expecting like a 45 year old
presidency not 70 yeah Razi whoa crazy
okay next story which was included at
the request of one Claudia I don't
remember everything you need to know
about Justin Bieber's feud with YouTube
star Joe Joe CY let me tell you why I
needed to be included one I just like to
consider I'd like to consider myself a
patron of all pop culture and if you
don't know just see you out right now
like you're behind second of all I have
a sister who's obsessed with being a
teenager and Fort knighting all around
her sister's wedding so it would behoove
you let's not make a wish TN and TN n TN
and TN n it would be the stars and it
would behoove you to know Jo Jo see what
if you really want to be in with the
kids I okay I agree so I'm gonna take
you from the top because I haven't read
this article and I honestly no clue
what's going on other than like I once
googled Jo Jo soo ah and I think I
figured out who she how I made you yeah
because you were like she's a deal with
Nickelodeon I guess she was once on
Dance Moms and that's how she like was
introduced okay so I personally found
out about her through a targeted
Facebook ad for one of her shows she's
playing in like Nassau Coliseum and I
was like who is this child who's selling
out arenas all over the world like in
Australia she's doing an arena and I was
like then I was like now I need to know
that's why I asked Jackie to go back on
Titian in need of a good celebrity for
you to take you into the new year of
course it's so we have just the one for
you a riveting squabble between Justin
Bieber and
by the way this is by refinery29 their
words so if anything's weird which they
probably will they you know who Justin
Bieber is Canadian pop star husband
slipper move oh wait that is such a
weird way to describe Justin Bieber he's
he's Canadian pop star international no
that makes it seem like he's big in
Canada right which I'm sure he is but
he's a global he's why didn't even need
to say that it's like that would be like
you know Obama former print like
everyone knows him like we wouldn't need
to say it's like Justin Bieber got into
it but you don't just say like a
description of like a biography you
don't Kim Kardashian selfie Queen Mary
Shelley right no that's so weird
Canadian pop star husband slipper mogul
are you aware of the slippers I'm also I
just think describing someone as a
husband is very odd
whatever it is such a weird article we
have to get through I know the party you
may be less like I guess they're trying
to prove the point that like you know
just me but do you know slightly less
familiar with is see what a
fifteen-year-old Dance Moms alum who was
now a YouTube star known for her large
hair bows and collaborations with the
likes of Colleen ballinger and the Paul
brothers the great Bieber CY feud began
as all things yeah that's like oh they
would read it in a textbook right the
great Bieber CY feud began as all things
do with a car customization company
based in South Southern California the
brand West Coast Customs oh that's where
the Kardashians go pin my ride oh yeah
we need exhibit here daily to break it
down sir about some justice where the
hell is exhibit I don't know
I'm worried about them never forget
someone in middle school like when this
show was on said to me they're like
you're like exhibit cuz you laugh at all
your own jokes it was like what would
astute observation ya know cost me that
is creating my boyfriend where did you
go Harvard the brand West Coast Customs
reposted an Instagram photo from see WA
who got a BMW for Christmas that was
decked out with rainbow rims to shorten
how to drive honestly a 15 like people
drive young these days
rainbow rims sparkly unicorn decals and
a blown-up photo of her face on the hood
that's so cool see what cannot legally
drive yet without a parent or guardian
president I just want to say respect
finer 29 answering the important
questions Bieber who follows West Coast
Customs on Instagram commented quote
burn it on the photo twice oh my god I
hate when Instagram comments do that
it's like he I know he didn't comment
twice I just like it was the best
picture of the car because I saw a
picture there was a cardboard cutout of
Justin Bieber inside of it but maybe
that's how she responded for sure so
then she a few days later she posted
another Instagram photo of the car this
time with a cardboard cutout of Bieber
in the passenger seat if you are the
kind of person who likes to think of
things in scale it may be helpful to
know that Bieber and C are both 5 9 at
least according to my uncle search I
conducted her caption burn it
oh good for her Bieber perhaps feeling
that the food had got more intense in
his original intent tweeted an apology
to see ba quote I have nothing against
you it was the car in the colors I
didn't like I really hope you didn't
think it was malicious or mean-spirited
see we're responding graciously saying
all was forgiven especially if Bieber
performs at her 16th birthday party
oh my god what kind of peanuts do it
I'll be so upset he has yet to respond
to her oh my god that would be so epic
and Justin but Justin Bieber is like in
this position like this moment in his
life where he like doesn't care about
his celebrity but like if he still had a
publicist on staff like she would make
him do this and that would be the
perfect way to end this story totally
but he seems like a nice guy these days
and like that is such a cute way to end
a feud it's like things got really
heated like they were litter with a
bunch of teenagers they were burning and
now she invited him to her birthday
party so when we did the deep dive it
now is his 50th birthday let me remind
you it does not say RSVP on the Statue
of Liberty so we did a we did a deep
dive on Jojo see well and there is it
very helpful and I hate to admit it buzz
feed article about Jojo see but like
here all the things you need to know and
the reason why she's gotten so popular
is because like she has this like
colorful dreamland like her room is like
when you were 6 like your [ __ ] dream
room like on crack with unicorns and she
is rolling in the dough she makes merch
that like sells out instantly like it's
just like her merch is like making
millions
she is Lunchables Jojo see what
Lunchables that sell at Walmart oh my
god yeah like she's [ __ ] killing it
like she has so many YouTube subscribers
her YouTube videos are killing it and
she's on this sold-out arena tour
that's it she has a song called dream
and the arena tour is sponsored or in
part
ship with Nickelodeon which is like
genius right so they're backing hard
which is great and then I realized too
real impact I was telling you when I was
watching a mana sands story and she was
talking about her her kids won't sleep
in their own bed at night they're always
sleeping with her so she's tried a few
different tactics to get them to stay in
their bed and one was then picking out
their own sheets instead of like I'm
sure the pretty Instagram she like made
well right and her daughter picked out
Joe just see what betting and now she's
sleeping through the night well I just
think this is so great I can just a
role-model Jing lives good but in
addition to being just like a positive
influence and role model for young girls
she's a gay icon like the gays are
obsessed really and that's why I was
like we need to get on board I need to
you're her song like I just need to
become a Joe just see what Stan and like
put a bow in my hair you know right and
I think she sells the bows obviously
good for her yeah like I just need to
know what who the team is behind her
because she's like a machine now well I
just like I appreciate the rise of
someone digital crossing over into
traditional who's a good influence for
young women and boys and girls yeah like
I'm mad respect
mad respect well that concludes our cast
5 now we're gonna jump into art by
segment which is called dear toasters as
you know you can always submit to dear
toasters if you email dear toasters at
gmail.com
it is completely anonymous and we just
we're looking for for some interesting
stuff something that makes me say damn
that's interesting you know I need your
scene factoid that's interesting we have
a follow-up should we do a follow-up
later okay
this one's titled long-lost sisters and
I haven't had the time to read it in
advance because we decided like five
minutes ago we were gonna do it so I'm
just there if it's bad bear with me
apologies in advance for the long email
I feel like all the details are
important but feel free to leave
anything out if it's too long to share I
was raised by a single mom and I never
met my biological dad my mom kicked him
out when I was an infant and he never
really cared to stick around he was into
drugs at the time I think my mom was 19
and he was 20 my mom is a great mom and
I really never wanted anything and had
great male role models like my grandpa
uncles and eventual stepdad my mom got
married when I was in the eighth grade
my stepdad that's like so ideal you know
mm-hmm like there's no father figure but
like everyone steps up you know right
and like she seems great yeah she's
she's not gonna and she has so much and
she's not gonna focus on much I just not
complaining get right
when I was a junior my stepdad is
incredible and we have always gotten
along really well when I was a junior
that's like um Bruce Jenner when he was
like the stepdad to other Christians
like he really filled a hole in their
life for sure but they had an amazing
dad too but when he passed right and
then they just got like a whole new dad
like they never had to feel like that
empty like house like without like
because Bruce just came and like picked
it up right where Robert left off yes my
stepdad ended up adopting me when I was
a freshman in high school and my
biological dad signed away his rights to
me my stepdad is incredible and we have
always gotten along really well when I
was a junior my biological dad emailed
me out of the blue and said he wanted a
relationship we emailed back and forth
for a few months and then that year he
sent me a birthday present he kind of
eventually disappeared and stopped
emailing and I didn't bothered above him
about maintaining the relationship that
was only the only contact I've ever had
with him my biological dad is now
married with two young daughters four
and six I'm 26 I found this out through
searching on Facebook and finding his
wife's page my mom never had any other
kids so the girls are my only biological
sisters and my stepdad has kids so I've
step-siblings so my question is do you
think I should reach out to establish a
relationship with my dad and hopefully
get to know my biological half-sisters
I'm worried they might be too young and
I never really knew my dad so would I
even have anything in common with him
would the wife be happy or upset if I
came back in the picture I'm really
happy with my family but not sure if I
would regret not having a relationship
with my biological dad and sisters thank
you so much for the amazing community
you have you created with love loyal
toaster my inclination is like No
well they're really young the girls like
so it's like but on one hand it's like
if they were you should wait till
they're older because they'll be able to
understand anymore but then on the other
hand it's like when they're older they
might have wished if you come into their
lives when they're younger it's more
normal it's like oh this is just our
sepsis you get to develop like this more
like long-term deep meaningful
relationship I'm sure their dad's not
gonna tell them about her so posted when
you're 15 and find out you have a
long-lost sister like that's stranger so
if I were her I would definitely reach
out and then assuming like like she's
our girl our toaster seems very cool and
very normal so assuming that the dad and
the new wife like are relatively normal
like they will welcome you and if
they're not then you don't want any part
of this anyway and if they don't want
you around or to meet their kids and
like you don't want it to be but I feel
like if that happens like then she'll be
upset whereas like she seems very like
happy with the way like she doesn't have
regrets like she doesn't feel like
anything's missing from her life it
seems like she's a full life so if she
does this and on the off chance like it
goes very wrong like then she has like
this tumultuous situation where she has
a happy life like maybe don't disturb
the peace if it ain't broke for sure but
then it's like when you think about when
I think about them the identical
stranger was obviously has to bring me
back to their when that like Nazi doctor
and Paulo Alberto is saying like do you
even need to know if you have another
sibling out there well I mean imagine
walking around this earth thinking that
you don't and then there are like two
people who are 50% of what you are like
right that's what's freaky I guess I
don't think of it that way look we have
a half-brother and it like he's just
like I was forget that like we're the
same dad you know any yeah it's just
like he's like David you know yeah but
then as we get older it is cool cuz it's
like it actually is and like he is a
spitting image of our dad so like when
we saw him in Olivia's wedding I was
like I'm gonna dad's here like that's
true I feel like we got her kids we
didn't appreciate it no and like we he
was always like way older than us and we
didn't like Live Together anything right
so we didn't like affect our childhoods
but now and especially having lost our
dad it really is a nice piece of [ __ ]
you should you should talk I agree yeah
start the relationship at least say that
you tried because maybe you will have to
wait until they're like 16 years old or
18 and then you can say I tried to reach
out and your dad wouldn't let me I'm
here for it I great you've changed my
mind Jackie I love changing hearts and
minds this is called sex addicted roomie
so may remaining I do not always get
along we are both in grad school I'm far
more busy than her her parents are
funding her entire life so she goes to a
few classes a week and then uses her
parents are what funding I thought you
said buddy I was like no funding her
entire life so she goes to a few classes
for me and then uses her parents credit
cards to party the rest of the time I
wasn't overly bothered by her lifestyle
until she started bringing home a
different guy every other night at 2:00
a.m. she does not know these guys and
feel as if they are starting to put me
in danger as more on more than one
occasion the guys had been so drunk that
they stumbled into my room instead of
hers after using the restroom I tried to
bring this up to her last week but she
really did not like what I had to say do
this one right yeah okay I went away for
the weekend last weekend and when I got
back my bed was made differently I'm
super particular about my bed I totally
understand that
I asked her about it and she said a
friend of hers stayed over and
accidentally slept in my bed because she
was too drunk that's weird but okay I
was a little disturbed but it's like
with a friend staying over and you have
the option of like sharing a better
there's literally a free bed like I
understand how we got here right they
continued um I was a little disturbed by
that because she thought of other people
sleeping in my bed is a little creepy to
me but I just washed my sheets and
forgot about it then I found out from a
mutual friend that she had sex with one
of the randoms in my bed what's so
disturbing about is that she literally
did this to spite me because she could
have just done it in her own bed 15 feet
away what do i do do I bring it up to
her oh my god I just don't know why cuz
you found out from someone else like and
she like you've been a proof of it so
she's like no I didn't yeah and this
girl sounds nuts and honesty reminds me
of a story of like some girls that I was
friends with like obviously we've grown
apart now but while we were all friends
and there was this one girl who would do
stuff like who would do this a very
similar situation like bring back guys
even if she wasn't like having sex with
them like just like go out does one
party and bring steal back and would do
that also [ __ ] and then one time her
apartment got robbed oh you're kidding
yeah and so she learned today well so
first of all this girl sounds like nuts
but then maybe there's a very small
small chance that this happened you know
people are drunk everything seems like a
good idea when you're drunk and maybe
she feels really bad and so if you bring
it up to her she might apologize and
like really feel badly she doesn't give
me that vibe but no but it's possible
because sometimes things do happen like
that like so I would bring it up to her
see how she reacts based on her reaction
either you say or you leave you can't
expect things to change if you never
bring it up but I don't know as someone
who might have thought she got away with
it and she's like phew I'll do it again
but it seems like this is a pattern but
based on her reaction you either stay or
you write you you have to give to see
where she's at give her a chance because
she is a friend but I just have to say
as someone who was like lived with
people like lived in a dorm a bed is a
sacred place and I think there is a
special place in hell for people who
like secretly let you sleep like I'm
cool like if you just told me like hey
my cousin's coming over like and she
sleep in your bed of course and then I
would just like get home and wash my
sheets but it's the lying that's like if
I don't know to wash my pillowcase I
could get lice no and I'm like so I I
lived in a dorm for my freshman year and
just drooler exactly I lived in the dorm
freshman year and it was a long weekend
and
went to NYU so like I lived 20 blocks
uptown so I just went home but my
roommate was from out of town so her
sister came into town I'm like I knew of
course it's too tiny dorm rooms and two
girls like they're gonna sleep in my bed
you know and I never asked me like
weren't friends but I never asked and
when I got back like everything was
different and I found a blonde hair on
my barb soap which is like my sacred
dove bar of soap you know and like
that's what got to be like I'm
understanding I have sisters like just
tell me like then I had to secretly wash
my sheets cuz I know exactly what you
did you know it's the lying that's the
problem yeah I don't know because I've
been on both ends of this and I dropped
the crud bad place but then I remembered
in college like my freshman year like I
was the perpetrator of this crime mmm it
was like someone that I was friends with
who also my roommate was friends with we
were just like hanging out and they like
sup in her bed and she was really pissed
which I understood I I believe I felt
really badly and like apologized said
well here's the air like if you like if
things happen so as long and also it's
not like you burned it to the ground
like you do is wash your sheets and it's
over you know the problem is that there
are people who it's like hey my friends
coming for the weekend can she sleep at
your bed they say if they say no you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] like people who say no
and don't want people sleeping in their
bed they're [ __ ] people who are just
upset about the lying that's
understandable right it's like when
there's two beds in the room and
someone's gonna sleep on the floor when
there's two available beds like couldn't
agree more but it's it's the cover-up
not the crime right this is called
caught on a plane what if you thought
you could get away with it wouldn't you
just but you couldn't like you in the
like you couldn't you can never get away
with anything like there's always
evidence and even it even if the person
didn't sleep in my bed I don't really
remember how I made my bed I'm gonna be
paranoid and just think you did it
anyway yeah so you might as well be
honest um okay it's nice living alone
totally now I appreciate it caught on a
plane I have the biggest Pitts and I
don't know what to do a couple of weeks
ago I was on a flight from LA going to
London I'm going because my boyfriend
and I are in a long-distance
relationship and I'm attending his
brother's wedding we've been doing this
for over three years
Tim London to LA is far mm-hmm anyway
we board the plane I'm standing on an
aisle see a cute blonde girl about early
30s comes and says she has the window
seat in my row so we get chatting she
tells me that she's meeting her husband
in London she lives in Oregon and he
lives in Belgium but they're meeting
there first
they just got married in May in Belgium
and she even shows me her beautiful
wedding photos she's a European marriage
he says she looks gorgeous and he looks
really handsome in love
he's a 12 year old kid from a previous
relationship but she seems to have a
great relationship with the kid anyways
I was like oh man oh that's crazy cuz
pietà had similar relationships and she
knows the same hardships of being in a
long-distance relationship yada yada
yada
she gives me a card and it's like if you
have any questions about the visa
process let me know I was like oh my god
thank you so much she got a marriage
visa to live in Belgium and this trip
was like one move away from her standing
there for good so then this guy who was
the middle seat sits down he's bald and
probably in his late 30s and has a thick
accent and I couldn't distinguish the
flight goes on in the girl orders a mini
champagne bottle she orders another and
then another then another and eventually
has ordered 12 [ __ ] mini bottles of
champagne throughout the entire 12 10
hour flight 10 hours is long yeah and 12
that's that's a glass an hour right she
constantly has to go to the bathroom
which is so annoying oh my god that is
so annoying
then our meal comments for this airline
you have to buy your meal with your
ticket the middleman did not know that
so the window girl says you know I'm not
gonna eat my meal and offers the man her
meal he's like thank you so so so much
and was so grateful
so she's bombed out of her mind at this
point she's constantly going to the
bathroom and being really in a way I'm
half asleep watching a movie and she's
like moving weird in her seat oh I'm
going to see him put his arm around her
but I just thought he was putting his
arm rest down or something but no they
were making out full tongue hands in her
hair making out this was going on
literally the entire flight she then
decides it's time to sleep and she lays
down on his lap with her face facing his
[ __ ] crotch he was like stroking her
hair and rubbing her back and I was like
what the [ __ ]
oh man that took over your turn it
rubbed me the wrong way and made me so
mad at her like she showed me your
wedding pics to shared with me how hard
it was being in a long-distance
relationship now it's all just [ __ ]
they literally were hanging out and
touching each other for over six hours
straight since she gave me your card I
found pictures it's all I found her
Facebook it's all pictures of her in her
husband pictures from their wedding I
found his Facebook too yes I guess they
could be in an open relationship but do
I message him or even her do I let karma
run its course I cannot stop thinking
about it I feel so weird holding this
information
[ __ ] but the [ __ ] out is not your
business just be glad that fight is over
just like I know the pit that everyone
has is like about her marriage like the
pit that I have it's like this weird
ball been taking advantage of an
obviously like inebriated woman right
yeah definitely don't message her
husband you don't know like what goes on
in people's
and like this is so not your problem the
only torch is like while you're sitting
there and like right back over
disgusting Oh clean breath you so it's
over I and this is something that comes
up like in the TI a often like if
someone you know information you message
the wife and like I always go back and
forth and I think it really always does
depend on the situation and the
situation like this do not know you have
no stake in this game you don't know
this girl personally like you met her on
a play and you also don't know him or
their relationship so this could very
well like be a normal thing and honestly
like yes even though people get drunk
and things happen like you don't just
get drunk and start making out with your
plane no up neighbor I would literally
didn't she say he was like gross yeah
and she said the girl was cute like a
blonde girl no so like well thank you
for opening up to us if you guys have
anything you want answered emails ear
toasters at gmail.com and we will we
will do it next week if we can remember
this has been the morning toast you've
anything else Wow no because we're
promptly ending at 11:30 anything else I
want to add um just per usual you know
follow pup with no job and took me
Thornton and me while you're at it
iam content all the way have an amazing
weekend if you're doing try January good
luck this is the first real test and I
know I'm gonna fail because everything
plans tomorrow I mean if you're not
doing drag January have a great [ __ ]
weekend party it up black out do what
you got to do backing out is God's Way
of saying forget about it
see ya
you